how's domra my name fella
welcome to black bear it takes place
somewhere in Europe inside a small town
with dark past the particular channel is
hit hard with the Black Plague during
the medieval ages inside the town there
are a castle which the villagers
believed that held hundreds of people
affected by the plague inside of it
almost to act as isolation centre from
the rest of the village the cattle has
been abated from 500 t reason claims to
help people have been wandering into
this old castle and not coming out of it
and one brave volunteer edwin Casman
[ __ ] epic name bruh surprisement
edward got damaged it's not epic anymore
Castle Kasim is a lie alright let's go
to an old creepy castle yeah I don't
really want to
we are already inside Castle exit can I
go [ __ ] we're at the shots right c'mon
bedrock day oh sorry pity I mean Simon
Simon you shouldn't hang out with people
like that
but they are cold they don't you can do
this there's nothing to be afraid of
what I'm not afraid afraid is my middle
name [ __ ] alright
all right notes to whoever finds this
means that probably did I make it
I'd go inside to get my brother we get
split up and reading this turn back now
that's a shame when they don't make it
don't like it waiting don't make it I
like to make it out and watch okay thank
you and no one is going to count me Dada
Dada Dada thank you
feels richer now I can Richie Rich
oh yeah alright pretty well lit up here
that is a miniature you could see mine
locked in no just blue sister waiting
pity nothing to be scared of nice people
in here probably have the castle still
holds the evil it once contained from
its past if you venture into it there's
no going back
bears locked the door what the hell do
you want me to do
alright I guess I'll just click second
floor first floor done now problem only
the door blew nothing out I'm not
suggesting I'm scared okay
whoa well is anyone in here it's just me
and I mean no one no one
no one it's out dere
pretty nice maps of titties maps of
titties
I would like one of those maps hey
mister with my map tears
yes please that is where the doctor used
to gather and discuss contribution
tractions for those affected by the play
who knows is their intentions to find a
cure disease the stick of fun of it
III remember when we studied Black Flag
in school as a little I was so like
freaked out about it was like talk about
stuff here how you penis note to self
don't talk about creepy please dad I
trust you
cut damn that was like a delivery all
right I need a key but I have a cake
come on brah be a bro man all right bro
man all right there's got to be one more
door who's that I trust you ha ha you
will die in hell today that was just a
taste shut up
you make me go back hi tricked you stop
stop this damn you piss me off alright
there's the door
I gotta know it opens anyway this is
[ __ ] it's awkwardly staring okay
but [ __ ] you what I tell you got it
right Georgia there must be another way
to pass this door
well I was wrong with the key man come
on I told you I don't talk to you
[ __ ] hate you all right it's gotta be
like a crowbar or an S baby Shh
not now Skelly man abre here we go
a fever headache and chills with
symptoms and a time to rush away doctor
that's right yeah not rest in my life
are those rads making love drats
not cool have an apple instead seriously
though kids [ __ ] public disgusting
mr. sheriff do you have a I need it's
probably underneath the beds well I'm
out of [ __ ] ideas
it's gotta be some other way huh well I
don't know I don't [ __ ] know I
probably missed something
come on man down hide stuff from me
lookit ah you're like a really bad
underneath here
that's receive that there we go oh sure
sure sure
all right found a secret door don't know
if I like okay nailed it okay
Wow dead people I don't know
hey bro you want an extra leg give it to
you you're welcome you're welcome
I guess I go in here [ __ ] jump that
[ __ ] come on man don't worry it's
[ __ ] creepy because I'm sorry I'll
just read you they are watching you you
know what [ __ ] I hate that [ __ ]
stop what stop stop looking at my ass
the true horrors of the castle lie down
the chamber although I believe the
Daurio to it is locked but I do remember
seeing a kid somewhere on the second
floor oh [ __ ] yeah what third floor exit
key all right cool you can keep staring
at me to share you [ __ ]
ah all right it's gotta be here right
place no I have cars okay jump on yours
Dana Dean if that's what his penis is
come but this is the third stop where's
the Atlanta pit okay okay okay not doing
wasting anything this difficult I need
to think I'm stuck how do I get up there
nothing that
stop watching me man
someone like you maybe I need to go back
Sameer super weak I don't really get
half of this stuff that's going on was I
supposed to find something for this I
didn't really get anything why I didn't
expect anything when I go back baby I
heard your screen over there are you
okay come on again come on good man
just need a new pad that's okay buddy
happens to the best of us all right
really I'm gonna be honest with you yeah
I pretty scared I know man I know my
chances are no but you must fight for
Wow
for what man I don't know I don't know I
got damn it huh it stepped aside
thank you [ __ ] ah damn it
stop rolling stop no I like the roller
because you own Cairo because all right
pretty cool okay they're not what hide
hit did you leave a present for me
please tell me this is it
no no [ __ ] me really confusing hey it
doesn't matter it doesn't do is it
doesn't matter you can't find the place
agape they you know I I casted can Oh I
than I look you have no lantern I
distracted you are my son of a [ __ ] why
would you distract me like the yes do
you like me
why didn't he you were nice anything you
were like idiot that's they don't judge
me man done Josh all right how's it
going in here
I hear fapping see what it looks like a
gangbang porno but I don't know I've
seen probably it's the only way I can
explain hey man how you doing
you had a bad day taking one down give
him a leg and turn that frown around you
say it's a torso I say it's a penis go
first smile and you walk for a while you
see your mise gangbang you take up your
hand you make it a high five and you
feel pretty awesome you have bad a this
share hey man hey
it's my team boom you want some cuddling
everyone wants cuddling man don't be
ridiculous
you have a nice and guess they're both
locked Oh Baba a monkey's Co this is my
last letter for whoever reading them
probably reading inside of these bodies
truly shows that doctors intentions were
not to help those with plague but to
slaughter them with the castle
oh no the castle is very dangerous just
to get out fast and as you can while you
still have small chance to
[Applause]
do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do
do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do dude what
the hell did not say how do they say
chamber good scale down from the ground
and baby
where the [ __ ] mr. chair calm down baby
shoutmon okay now I've got damn it
alright Betty wait I'm with you
don't worry be careful don't do anything
rushed
it's so [ __ ] dark
alright back then I guess huh here we go
guys we'll see you next episode or
whatever salesman yes
I'm coming gasping gave a gasp stop wait
just take oh my god oh my god oh my god
pity what the hell aah
what